hi slugs we have bert kreischer on today
and it's awesome and it never ends it
never ever stops i can't wait for you to
watch and this weekend is very important
because i'm going to be in brooklyn and
in dc and i know that tickets are almost
gone so please get them and come see me
it's going to be so much fun and after
that i will be in chicago and
minneapolis i can't wait to see you guys
the road has been the best i'm so
excited to get back on it see me this
weekend in syracuse at the funny bone i
will be in san jose california i'll be
in burbank dania beach florida omaha
nebraska
west nyack new york austin texas
pennsylvania pittsburgh
tempe
arizona
kansas city missouri irvine and many
other dates go to andyletterman.com
[Music]
he came into travel channel
and was uh hey how do my cheeks look
are they are they super red
you're they're a little red but um i
sauntered today and so my my cheeks i
was in the sauna for 45 minutes and so i
got out and i was like goddamn i'm gonna
look like alcohol in your house yeah i
have two songs do you have a cold plunge
i have two how long did you do this
i do
have two of these
three houses
so yeah so uh from travel channel to
three houses everybody no i know
which house is the magic happen in right
now the beach house is the first i want
to get on bert level how long do you
call plunge for four minutes oh i only
do three well louise share lacey what
lacey mackie's my girl too oh that's oh
that's right of course yes that's right
you're sober i forgot i told lacey well
i don't wanna know it from santa fe have
we started i used to live in new mexico
okay great i know i'm from santa fe yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he like helped you
get sober or something yeah yeah you had
foot and mouth disease yeah i had i
think about that all the time i think
about that all the [ __ ] it wasn't
football that i had trench mouth drinks
about that my teeth almost fell out
it's what homeless people get
i drank so much that my gums were like
oh my gums went up how did you reinforce
them back
i just stopped drinking and you were
drinking you were drinking like like i
remember talking to you about this and
and i because i always talk to people
like nick thune is like the canary in
the mine yeah cause you remember you
ever hear nick's story
no i on it i just know he was brought
religious so he must really have drank
he got a bottle of [ __ ] vodka and
went to the desert to die oh lord he was
like fear and loathing and you were like
you were like you'd wake up all just
scraped off oh i would chop my teeth in
the morning and i would call i call i
nicknamed i had a boyfriend we nicknamed
jack daniels oj we go past the o.j so in
the morning when he feels like guilty
like throw me the oj we i drank yeah
it's kind of a surprise she still has
her nipples attached i know i i really
did almost lose this one for real yeah
and then on stage i tell people i
skidded off my uh my i thought she was
gonna say it got shot off on a drug deal
gone bad oh my god that'd be so cool i
know miss pat and i do have some
parallels but hers are like hers are a
little more gangster
but i did know i skidded on i crashed i
had a yamaha zuma
and i was blackout drunk and i woke up
in my friend's house it looked like my
throat had been slit like there was just
blood gushing from like and i was
wearing this little dress and cowboy
boots i looked cute when i drank
um but i yeah this yamazuma and i
couldn't find the scooter i just
remembered someone i didn't like had
found me
and that's the only vibe i just had the
feeling someone that didn't like me
helped me when i crashed and i had to
put all the pieces together because i
couldn't figure it out i went to the
hospital i had to get like nine stitches
on my chin
i cuts all over my face i had a cut from
another drunk scooter accident the week
before i'm sorry but can we get like a
tax rebate or something that we like
work with her now
like we've rehabbed her have you ever
relapsed no i never i never well i do
like drugs i i called i called the when
you know we did this
you did the tour and then the cove hit
and they're like hey you need to rename
your tour and so like uh
like uh nate pargotsy called his rain
check right you know you had to like
acknowledge because you had to
acknowledge that it was supposed to
already happen you'd acknowledge that
they already bought tickets for it so
you didn't want them to buy tickets
again for it you know so you because it
was already sold out so you had to say
hey these are this is that tour if
you're wondering it's back it's two
years later and so i called mine the
birdie boy relapse tour and boy i got a
lot of a lot of people upset well good
everyone in recovery everyone in
recovery is like there's not something
to joke around about i was like for me
it is well the funniest thing is the
bars that are called like the 13th step
because 13 stepping in the program means
there's 12 steps in the program and by
the way i went to aaa for three months
and then i got my three month coin and i
was like peace this is as long my
relationships always last see later
like i was out like i broke up with aaa
and it helps a lot of people and i'm
grateful for it for that three months i
have nothing to do with it esther do you
want to introduce the show oh oh welcome
to trash tuesday a podcast
starring three women made of old sperm
and uh that's an old farm that's aging
now we have some aging sperm we have
bert christian
my uh yeah i'm turning 50 next year i
don't really think i don't really think
about age because i feel like very young
the only thing i think about i think
about death every morning when i wake up
oh that's usually what i started dying
every night from your gerd yeah it's
gerd it's gerd and i have this
is
i have it too you can't eat for like
three hours yeah so my window is after
eight pm i'm done i cannot consume
anything or else like i choke you choke
and i have a hospital bed one of those
hospital beds where i like sit up like
my boyfriend just has to like sleep up
with me because we don't have the tube
that's true i have six pillows behind my
head i sleep in in like 90 degrees yeah
but if i sleep on my back i go like this
oh do you have sleep apnea
i know that
i'm tactile i have tactile issues okay
so anything i can't have something on my
[ __ ] face while i sleep wait did you
go to occupational therapy when you were
a kid uh no i should have you i think we
have the same things uh yeah we
interrupt we talk a lot i interrupt
non-stop but it's 80d yeah
all right and i'm it's we i got i lo
island i got the same [ __ ] wait you have
um because i have hsb what is that i'm
highly sensitive person so sensory thing
that is so cute why did you just become
a little like
woodland creature when you said that so
it's so sensory things do bother me but
i'm not um so some tactile things bother
me like the the the way certain fabrics
feel on my body i will not ever wear
wool like well
i could have grown up in russia when i
was a kid if not if the seam of socks
were on the edge i would it would ruin
my entire life like i would cry i would
scream like i wouldn't live did you have
this oh no no no no no no no no god
who's going [ __ ] an animal could put
on tube socks in the 70s and have that
seam on the tip of their toes
what kind of animal that i'm like
i have i i've there are certain socks i
i wear
uh i will only wear a couple pairs of
socks
uh
i like i like the banana republic makes
a nice dress sock that it's thin i need
thin socks i can't wear thick socks i
have recommendations so do i and one of
them is skims
do i have boys
no but skims is kim kardashian's like
shapewear line but they make really thin
socks that are really soft also i just
ordered seamless things seamless oh uh i
need my pants to be stretchy oh my god i
get because because that's more about me
being fat the uh i uh i'm a big
flip-flop guy i'm like because i feel
like like i have to wear i'm not i'm
just
i couldn't you know i couldn't wear
shoes like keds and stuff as a kid i
couldn't wear shoes heads were trash by
the way it's like they're like toms but
they didn't give donate to children in
any way it was like i thought they were
like running shoes weren't the heads
were like
they were like the shoes that you would
wear to gym class i guess back in the
day but it was they were trash kids were
nothing they were nothing i'm kind of in
awe of people who can wear jeans on a
plane or a long-haul flight
okay wait i i live in my sweatpants but
i've converted a little bit to loose
comfortable jeans
broken in yes oh by the way this is my
diet tip i forget this is good for you
too
you don't have to lose weight just buy
pants that are too baggy and then people
go i see you losing weight i swear to
god it works i'm not even kidding like
if you get like stretchy pants and
they're a little bit too big yeah people
are like i see your attic girl i'm like
i know
working hard like talk about my back
pocket esther came out with um a
sweatpants um line that is so
comfortable it speaks to me so loudly
it's all i wear on the plane because the
way this seems the way it sits on oh my
god annie that's my after my scooter
accident which by the way i used to get
bracelets that was my joke i would give
bracelets to the guys i banged are
friendship bracelets
wait that's actually so funny yeah
it was really funny
yeah i almost lost my nipple
yeah i'll get french fries tingling just
looking at the picture boner boner no no
no no castle tingle you guys ever get
that when you like like if someone's
like uh well it's like you're keegan
kind of so yeah it's almost no but it's
it's almost like a sensation in your
[ __ ] where it goes like
her piece does that too oh dude i
honestly think herpes wouldn't be that
bad and then i had someone tell me about
getting herpes yeah and it was they were
like it is
soap uh i wanna say who it was
i wanna say it was joe list yeah joe
loves you talking about it
yeah you said this i love when people
talk about their herpes by the way
there's a female comic that did it she
opened for me one time she talked about
getting herpes and it made me think she
was more sexy yeah i was like i was like
her vulnerability i was like [ __ ] yeah i
wish liam and i did have herpes because
then that would mean we'd never cheat on
each other yeah because it's you have
that commitment because you're like
young kids are very open about it now
because i know like um
a couple college girls call it eight
college age girls who are very open
about their yeast infections they're
herpetic source but you're right herpes
from a friend of mine god i want to say
her name so bad don't say her name
kalyala but a friend of mine she has to
you guys have the same name
but basically when she gets an outbreak
she has herpes too which is the genital
herpes not typing which is kind of the
better one no no no
one is a little you get less frequent
outbreaks
everyone's got to be in your business
but you can still herpes three
that's your [ __ ] that's the one you
know i know a girl that has three we've
all had herpes because we've all had
chickenpox chickenpoxes oh and i had
yeah and um uh shingles yeah and
shingles is her pets shingles yeah how
have we not talked about this when did
you have shingles it's so funny you're
the most elderly person i've ever met
that you're so excited about this i had
it i was 19 years old and i couldn't
believe it i was like am i gonna get
yellow fever next like what is this i
thought it was for old people it is for
old people
i got it when i was 19 i was a nursery
school teacher and
you know when you work around little
snot-nosed kids bert as a grown
snot-nosed kid i thought you said for
two seconds i thought you said i was a
nursery rhymes teacher yes i used to
hickory dickory dock
but i dropped the beat i was like
hickory dickory [ __ ] doc
um but yeah no and i got because the
kids like my immune system was so like
over wrought by children
i had it at like 25 and it was
it was thrilling that is crazy
but the pain you felt is similar to the
pain people feel when they have an
alcohol is it neurological yeah because
the ganglia the nerves in that area is
what's really ultimately what's painful
about it it's not you know i had a i had
a i had a
so i have like ocd i've tried i'm sure
i've talked about this before
but uh
yeah i had i've only been with six
people right women i don't know why i
said people women and so i yeah you've
been yeah well no no no because how many
have you been with what
what how many minutes
zero zero yeah
there's still time
so
so uh i
but my very first time was very just
horrific it was a nightmare i [ __ ] it
up so bad of course
yeah every way you could ever think of i
couldn't put the condom on properly like
i unrolled it all the way and then went
to slide it over like a sock well i say
putting it on is the improper part
don't you party bird and then then when
i did get it in get it on i got on top
of her and it happened so quickly it
overwhelmed me and i was like shaking
and then she said are you gonna put it
in and i looked my dick was between her
butt cheek i knew i was literally gonna
ask because i there was a guy in my high
school that [ __ ] between a girl's ass
and the couch yeah yeah oh he really
that's what i used to offer up when i
didn't want to have sex i'm like do you
want the inside of my knee like really
this was pre-skull [ __ ] yeah pretty
much if i knew that was an option yeah i
mean
chicks i would have [ __ ]
meniscus [ __ ]
yeah
so that is appealing to you you would be
into that like this just this part i
would be into so i i there were so many
chicks that i've been with
that i
wanted to have sex with but i thought i
thought i would perform so poorly that
they would then like i had to really
trust you to have sex with you like i
had to trust you and i only had
one
maybe two one night stands
and um
i think
and um
one of them
uh did not wear a condom
uh he didn't wear condom no i didn't
no he wore one i didn't
i didn't i put one on also that's so
cool oh my god you put them on together
matches twinsies how does me put it on
got him help him [ __ ] me in the ass
so uh and so and i worked at barnes
noble and there was this gay dude named
andrew and uh he had gotten he's he was
going he was [ __ ] a lot and he was
like hey man uh can he just come out of
the closet from like omaha or something
and he was like we just got out of the
basement take the freight elevator and
talk smokey joint [ __ ] tell me about
his one-night stands it was really cool
i didn't know any gay dude so it was
really eye-opening and it was like
like you know people talk about uh
wanting to be better or learning about
things but it was like for real i really
wanted to yeah i didn't know any gay
dudes i was probably homophobic growing
up and so it was like if you were
homophobic you probably wouldn't have
gone down that freight elevator yeah to
be honest oh yeah yeah i think i was
just i didn't know anything about people
would be like you're like scared of
people like leaning in for a kiss or
whatever you know like i'm cool with gay
dudes as long as they don't like hit on
me yeah you know that one like it's a
very late 90s line yeah right yeah
and so we go down and he would and he
he was like
i think i might have gotten bit on the
dick by a spider and i was like really
and he goes he goes can i show it to you
and i was like yeah the spider or the
dick is
no he took his dick out he showed it in
his there was something going on with
his dick that's what louise said to me
he said i think it was bit by spiderman
just kidding he never pulled his dick
out i was like what the hell
here's a plan
no wait that was that was weinstein how
do you think i feel i was
never mind never mind
you guys
[Music]
dipsy
is very important that you know about it
it is an app full of hundreds of short
sexy audio stories designed by women for
women now i know a lot of people in my
life that this is like the big turn on
like a sexy story and there's really no
where to find them all in one place and
dipsy is finally doing that for us we
don't need to be watching hardcore porn
on camera all right i am more feminine
than that i'm sorry i'm not and it's
just sometimes i just want a nice hot
story about your hometown crush and you
can kind of like use your imagination
you know it's
no it's true you get the audio and then
your mind goes wherever you'd like it to
go like hold up with your hot yoga
instructor
guys is that a thing for you carlos but
they don't just have like sexy stories
sleep stories wellness sessions and now
they also offer written stories todd
walked in on me when i was doing a
wellness session
it was very embarrassing wait did that
really happen that's my worst fear
no you just have to go i was waiting for
you to finish me off
you have to be like
it worked you have to pretend
you guys dipsy is your go-to place to
spice up your me time explore your
fantasies or heat things up with a
partner with dipsy your sanctuary is
waiting escape into a world where
pleasure is your only priority it is fun
to go with to listen to them with your
boyfriend you put one you know plug each
ear with one pod
plug one hole with a tod
for listeners of the show dipsy is
offering an extended 30 day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
tuesday that's 30 days of full access
for free when you go to d-i-p-s-e
stories dot com slash tuesday
dipsystories.com
tuesday
let's talk about how mentally unwell
every single one of us is right now
how better help is essential we listen
we can't always rely on our parents to
tell us to stop vaping sometimes you
need to go to better help and see what's
going on inside internally you need to
check out betterhelp.com trash tuesday
some would say maybe because you've just
no notice that ants are following you
and all over your purse and your things
maybe you need help
you guys better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist that's
so crazy how many ants are on her and
it's i thought i was like is she having
a psychotic break is this like no she no
there's time for you to be able to
handle this right now is actually i
think we need to shout out better help a
little louder because free this is a
therapist did this for you it's actually
well it's theory it's therapist it's
also
experience you know i've had ants
covering me for years wow time to time
season for me
you guys
connect in a safe and private online
environment it's so convenient and you
can start communicating in under 48
hours my favorite feature about better
help is the journal feature which you
can just kind of write down your
thoughts and your poems maybe my poems
my email poems did you have to go to
better better help after we laughed when
you read just your poem esther fell
asleep
like these [ __ ] laughed at my poems
you guys we want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 percent off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com trash tuesday join over 1
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health like me and all
these ants again that's
betterhelphelp.com
trash tuesday
[Music]
you know that was a podcasting used to
be like just talking [ __ ]
and then getting home and getting a
phone call
like that was every podcast i ever did
with brogan was i just do it and then i
get a phone call
from everyone everyone i ruined so many
friendships
that i was like the reason i'm friends
with rogan joey and tom and arya's
because that's that's what i talk [ __ ]
about that's why i talk [ __ ] too about
other people
so uh
but yeah yeah but i want to get back to
the um spider bite on the dog
shows me his dick and i go this is
before the internet so this is 1997 98
the internet was around but you couldn't
use it on your phone you had to get to a
computer where barnes and noble
and so we went up to the medical
thing the thing we looked up venereal
diseases
and i
and then that day
taking a sh [ __ ] in barnes and noble
i said maybe i should look at my dick no
i was unaware that you can't get a
neural disease within uh
eight hours ten hours it can't show it
was not gonna show up that quick but i
spun myself into a circle of course that
was so bad it was what it was is the
i never really examined my dick i guess
and the uh when you know like a
circumcision scripture that's real
there's like a ring of color around your
dick yeah it's like it's and i looked at
it and i was like what the [ __ ] is that
never really paid attention to my dick
much and now i'm looking at it
so i said you know what it's not
probably nothing i start spinning out
ocd legit spinning out i go to the
the met the store right by west force uh
subway stop the there was a dwayne reed
i get tinactin
my spray tanactin on my dick
yeah and then this spiraled out into a
like almost like a manic episode where i
i remember at one point i was and i was
soaking my dick and balls in white
vinegar
drinking a 40 smoking a joint walking
watching quantum leap that's how i
douche too that's also how i do i love i
don't
know
why it's so great vinegar white vinegar
google it
actually this is all you could find on
the internet back then this is 1997 98
and it got so bad
were you too scared to like go to a
doctor because you were afraid of the
diagnosis too was it like one of those
things like i just want to try to like
get it away probably i figured i could
solve it myself
and then i ended up i ended up really
kind of spiraling out of control like
mentally um and i i remember being in
philadelphia and i remember drinking i
was drinking a lot of drink in the
morning to shut up the voices in my head
because it was just they were just like
go to the bathroom look at your dick
look at your dick go to the bathroom
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
look at your dick one more time look at
your dad have you looked at your dick
with the mirror mirror look at the look
at the underside of your deck like yeah
it was just over and over and my mom
called my roommate and she was like i'm
i'm having a hard time getting in touch
with bert
and he was like he was like i think
i think he's having i think he's going
through something and so my mom i was at
penn station and my and i called my mom
at a pager i think and i called my mom
and she said hey
go out to laguardia there's a plane
flight for you to come home we're gonna
bring you home and i was like all right
and in my head i was like i need that i
actually need to come home i don't feel
good i'm like my brain's not working
right i go to la guardia get on a flight
fly home
and
my grandmother
my grandmother gave me this necklace my
grandmother was there
uh we had a glass of white wine
and i said to my mom i need to go see
your um i'd like to see a dermatologist
and she was like okay i don't know what
you're going through but whatever i said
so i went to a dermatologist i showed
the dermatologist my dick we were going
to see why did her panic that night and
like the dermatologist was like i just
do facials
oh my god i'm just going to do the
t-zone that's how you got arrested
i showed the dermatologist my dick and
and he was like oh wow have you been
have you been playing messing with it oh
my gosh you were just spraying i said
yeah and he goes what have you been
putting on your dick and i said pretty
much everything he goes all right stop
you're like i said i think i've got
something i don't know what i have
anyways you have nothing you have
nothing but your dick is extremely
irritated so what i'd like you to do
is for real
don't touch it don't play don't stop
messing with it and then i didn't
believe him i didn't believe him i
didn't take his diagnosis i didn't
believe him and i just went all right i
stopped
touching my dick you want to talk about
[ __ ] crazy every time i had an
obsessive thought about it i would say a
prayer to saint jude and it would go
away because i didn't want to do the
saint jude prayer yeah saint jude and so
that i started leaving
your penis i know she didn't know it i
wish i could tell her now my um my mom
was in town when i got crabs she was
visiting me in santa fe [ __ ] nothing
i would like no but it was but when you
don't know when you're all that's
something you're itching and burning
there's still time when things are
pitching and burning in your crotch it's
like
great it's crazy i was like mom
something's wrong down there bert i can
really relate to that because i think
that when i was younger there was um a
very big push to be ultra hygienic down
there with the lady bits and my mom was
like wash wash wash and until it wasn't
until i was actually like almost like 11
where she was still like manually like
washing me down there really and i was
like
it was so weird so like when i got older
i had this thing where it's like not
even a drop of urine i couldn't i had to
sit on a toilet and pee if i even felt
so much as like a drop of urine in there
and then i would overwash and scrape and
irritate myself scrape
with like my fingernails like i would
like like
you know catch a nail everyone's
creeping like in between and stuff and
then it wasn't until i went to um my
first gynecology appointment where she
was like you have to stop using harsh
soaps yeah um just over washing you got
to let your own flora get there because
i was getting like just really bad
irritation because i was obsessed with
quote-unquote cleanliness and not having
ascend and but you weren't sexually
active at that point that was before
even when i was sexually active it
became worse then it was always just
inspecting and making sure oh i used to
think i had herpes like i i was to the
point where i was like i just want
herpes like i'm like show like give me
back carpet like give me back my stuff
like i just was like screaming like i
just like was so sick of the anxiety of
thinking i had it and all my friends
kept getting in i'm so jealous of people
that can just [ __ ] like crazy and don't
think about it like i had friends in
college
never work on them never thought about
it never like huh my roommate in new
york at the time
i remember he got a chick pregnant and
they got an abortion and he was like and
i was like i remember him joking you're
so jealous he was like i've had more
abortions then you've had sex with
people
and i was like and i was like why did
you never work you're not worried and he
was like what are you gonna do i was
like what do you mean what are you gonna
do like
oh i when i started dating land right
before we had sex first time i was like
just you know i
i'm pretty sure i have uh something a
venereal disease that's been undiagnosed
yeah i did that she looked at my dick
she was like there's nothing
wrong with your dick and i was like i
know not now she's like there's nothing
right
there's nothing there's nothing right
with it either but there's nothing wrong
with it
no my boyfriend i do the same thing like
i
when we first started dating i thought
like i just convinced myself there was
something wrong with my like i was like
i think i have like chlamydia or
something and then i went to the doctor
and um
they were like you literally have
absolutely nothing but i like conv i was
like i had so convinced myself i was
having like light bleeding because it
was i did end up having like a little
bit of a yeast effect it was like a tiny
little thing but it was like the
littlest thing and i just my brain
just went because don't you always feel
like finally it happened to me or like
or whatever but you weren't a sexually
active i really relate to this like not
even in the std ways although but you
guys saying like especially what you
said about like
you could not rest you had to go and
check you had to like to me i i call
that like checking with my therapist but
i've had it with like oh i know now i
have blank disease and like i cannot
rest i have to google it
what would you think what's an example
just like non-hodgkin's lymphoma
literally i thought i had that one time
anything like because i
because typically that problem no like
ms i remember you were very worried for
a while about like gastrointestinal pla
pain
i remember i mean i was like
extreme hypochondriac everything i
thought i had because then the anxiety
makes gives you this you really stop
having this and yeah because i started
taking lexapro because i realized like
oh this is this is anxiety like this is
really severe anxiety you shouldn't be
like thinking i have to check again i
have to google this i have to like
that's crazy when we got pregnant with
georgia
i forced leanne's gynecologist
to draw blood from me and leanne and
test us for everything i was like and
yeah i thought i thought i had
everything i thought i had your friend
about all those abortions probably i
know and he's probably shivering in july
i remember my mom was there when we got
my mom was in the room with us when we
got all our tests back from everything
and they do that also when you are
giving a birthday test you for
everything anyway yeah but um i remember
saying and when when and when
it all came back negative and i still
didn't believe it i was like i was like
well it's almost like you're attached to
like the anxiety of it it's almost like
you're like i do you feel uncomfortable
i think sometimes the anxiety makes me
know i won't die if i don't have the
anxiety then my plan will die yeah can
you take us on a private jet
yeah okay
i just really just realized that i
thought oh by the way josh had a really
good time with you on the road josh
potter oh yeah like a really good time i
was like tell me [ __ ] everything
i'm like manifesting your life like
party tell me every detail and i'm
literally just imagining it's me we
party really
but not but not like not like falling
off a scooter ripping our nipples off
party yeah i had to stop i had two stuff
that's why i started fully loaded uh the
obvious the festival i'm putting
together for two weeks in june because i
wanted to yeah i have still doing offers
to people we're adding people as it goes
but uh it's dave
it's david by the way not not far off
i'd be totally into something like that
the design of the thing too thank you so
what i what happened was we did i i
i'm a i'm a panic brain this all this
panic brain works in our benefit
sometimes my special comes out on
netflix the whole lockdown happens and i
decide i want
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna stay home
i'm gonna create something so i called
my managers and agents and i said uh i
want to do drive-in movie theaters and
we found an edm
festival promoter who could produce edm
shows outdoors and so we just mixed it
we just we just created a thing and i
had so much fun doing it
meaning the
idea of being outside the sun sets the
the unpredictability of like rain
earlier every morning it's like a party
and it's inviting pre-party everyone
would get there early and tailgate i
remember the first one we did the line
was like three miles long to get in you
call it taylor gate when taylor thomas
is doing it just a little bit daily tail
okay not a bad idea
by the way put it on a shirt so uh so i
was like i want to do this i want to do
this with
my my com my friends yeah i want to take
them out i want to show them how we did
these outdoor festivals
and they're going to love it yeah and so
i i got it i got a deal on some minor
league baseball stadiums
because yeah and so i was like i was
like let's do four minor league baseball
stadiums two amphitheaters an arena and
a raceway and we got tour buses i got
i'm doing it the way i do it ivs in the
morning tour buses around take us
everywhere if you have a short bus you
can bring us on that one listen
we're we are still
right our first round of offers were to
then you know the na the big names that
you could would move pre-sales and then
now we're just adding more comics we're
bringing as the more stickers you sell
the more people you can bring the bigger
the event event gets and so it's been
it's been funny [ __ ] and i can't wait
and my wife is like
my wife is like this morning is like i
want to get everyone matching tracksuits
so that they have them i want everyone
to have we should get like yeti tote
bags that are coolers and we'll fill it
with weed and an iv oh my god i want to
be adopted by you guys i can't hold it
in any longer you gotta sell tickets
guys yeah we gotta tell tickets that's
the number one the first guy i wanted
was to tell obviously
[ __ ] gotta tell you and the second
you gotta tell everyone's like yeah i'm
in yeah because it's a tell it's [ __ ]
to tell he's the greatest and so uh yeah
we're doing two weeks in june and then
if this goes well we'll do a bigger
festival next year and keep doing it and
can i ask you a question and i don't
mean to offend you you cannot offend me
or how much do you want are you jewish
53 no i'm not
i'm not i really got juice vibes when
you
said that it covet happened and you're
like i didn't want to just sit at home
and you're like i'm calling drive-in
movies i'm like that's i just got you
vibes sorry
i loved it i got it in the best way i
got to the place in my career where i
can because i always have horrible ideas
right like i've always had not horrible
ideas just out-of-the-box ideas where
everyone's like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so like i remember saying
to tom
uh one time we were doing two bears i
said we should start a sports management
company and he was like what i was like
yeah start a sports management company
we'll get athletes and we'll manage them
we'll promote them on our podcast we'll
promote them we have a big out we have a
big fan base
and
we'll sign them
we'll get our agents to negotiate their
deals but we'll sign them and and we can
really blow up some athletes and he was
like he's like i don't know about that
literally and by the way i'm not saying
anyone stole anything i'm just saying
literally six months later
bar stool starts bar stool sports
management and it's [ __ ] one of the
biggest things yeah and tom called me
goes i will never shoot down another one
of your ideas
because they're weird i may not get them
i just need to get behind you so right
now i have that brain too so just wait
carlos will you tell bert your idea just
to sign with the nil deals going away
with the ncaa yes thinking trash tuesday
could sign like some athletes around
like uc irvine something like that oh
inspect it's a brilliant idea yeah and
and you start your sports management
company and by the way you get one
athlete that blows up exactly and all of
a sudden you're well i've had a similar
idea for tiger belly for years and it's
basically to sponsor because we produce
insane boxing talent from the
philippines
and this is
[ __ ] genius so what in but the
philippines the philippine sports
commission and because i grew up in that
um you know being a swimmer there and
being very underfunded and under
resourced and not getting a lot of help
as an athlete so so much so that i came
to america to swim division one here and
you know
i didn't have that in the philippines so
i was thinking bobby and i were like
well let's just sponsor a bunch of
really young boxers
and kind of like
you know get them to the big stage get
them everything they need um everything
from like
you know all their educational needs and
beyond like we got them and i think that
is such a smart thing to do that is
actually a brilliant idea
because i think a filipino boxer you
give them 20 bucks a year and that
pretty much covers everything right yeah
right yeah and it's like you'd be you'd
be surprised how much they can already
do on their own yeah that it's like you
know these guys are already so talented
and they have so little it's like
imagine if you actually like gave them
everything they needed uh have you seen
the king richard documentary or the
movie movie not yet i honestly it turned
into boxing
yeah
i've been like
the way they used to do tennis players
is uh nick bolieri and all these guys
would
would basically say hey
i got a huge camp down here i got
funding from whatever what you call it
come down i want 50 of all future
earnings
and and
it paid off with i mean
you think about venus and serena how
much that guy made out with 15 of all
future earnings now tom and i were
saying doing three percent like
something so minuscule we don't want the
money something didn't acknowledge that
we were part of the team something to
invest us in it we just started uh two
bears racing
i was imagining literally two bears
racing each other i was like that's
great that's a brilliant idea that would
be not brilliant that's an animal of you
sandy i don't know you give them the
treat there's honey at the end i thought
you meant bears like two gay guys yes
carlos is racing
all those are applicable guys no tom's
into racing and there's a thing i we
were talking about la colombe well yeah
she probably shouldn't tell you everyone
where you guys are but we were talking
about um
when i worked at travel channel the one
thing that they said to me that really
translated for throughout my life is
passion begets passion if you find
someone passionate about something you
don't have to do anything they can talk
to you about their passion all day long
if you bring up stand-up comedy with me
we're done that's all i want to talk
about the only thing i really give a
[ __ ] about
and so
tom's really obsessed with racing he
loves racing his he is uh he's a coach
he goes out and runs drives cars how
that's what he has fun in and so i
watched this formula one thing and it
seemed interesting wait the documentary
on netflix yeah it's the greatest i've
i've blew through season four and so i'm
like i
i thought
i wonder how i get tom in a formula one
car
and then i thought and then i know from
travel channel there are small races all
around the country every weekend people
are really passionate about it there's
like a whole there's a whole like farm
league of people that are trying to get
up to the top
and i thought well you know with with
our notoriety we could probably
skip some steps yeah and so i decided
said to him are you interested in if i
started if we started two bears racing
would you be interested in being our
race car driver and he lit up and he
like lit up by way that i was like i was
like oh it's almost like he was like
he's like burp bud light's sponsoring us
i'm like what shut the [ __ ] up
so uh that happened but they did sponsor
us i think we [ __ ] that on up
so on this show we have a thing called
trash tank where it's basically we pitch
horrible business ideas that's horrible
but business ideas that fit with our
theme we write our vibe yeah not
horrible she's correct um what are some
ideas
i'm the only one that's pissed
down where you look back on and you're
like holy [ __ ] i cannot believe i
actually pitched that idea uh oh i mean
like for us it was like come rags but
you know no no i think comrades is a
good one uh
thank you
i've always uh my big
invention i've been sitting on for years
that no one's ever
taken me up on
is i want to make urinal men
what is that so you know in a urinal
there's a urinal cage with urinal mint
in it i wanted to create busts of famous
people like uh like saddam hussein or
putin
in plastic with their mouths open
that you could put on to a urinal cage
and you could put something and you
could piss in their mouths
i don't know where the money is to be
made in this i think it's because
urinals are public so it's like that
would have to be like the restaurants
would have to get yeah but no but you
just do advertising on it or something
like like my and then i morphed it i
said what if we got heineken to do it
and you could put a can
over that and it would say hey put the
put the beer back where it belongs and
so people could piss in the can just
something to like like that was no you
know what it should be it should be like
a like a contest so like if you can piss
like to a certain level you like it
dings or something like it doesn't have
to be like a huge reward tricky thing is
what brand wants to be pissed on but is
it is it us but also honestly by the way
hold on yeah for this reason i mean
this is [ __ ] brilliant do you know
how big your podcast would be
if you just did a bust of three of you
right very small like with your mouths
open that goes over their own cage and
it just says trash tuesdays and it's
like [ __ ] the billboard let's do that
yes
and it's like and it's like and then you
have that would be well guys you just
shove their dicks in it and not pee no
guy's putting his dick
you know what's so funny if you got
enough money into this how fast all of
the bathrooms would all of a sudden be
unisex like what i mean like no one
would be fighting about the trans
bathrooms or anything because they'd be
like there's money to be made let's put
the dicks in the [ __ ] girls room
that was an idea i had i was i was i had
a list of ideas because uh i really
thought i really thought i i mean i told
one to tom i wanted to do a
because we do live events and our live
events are pretty big
i said what if we took our live event
and we just all the money we get from it
we invest in three fans and so all our
fans pitch us ideas
and then we take the top 10.
for the live event for the live event we
hear 10 pitches
thank you on that live event we then
take and invest you know whatever money
we make which is somewhat sizeable at
times and we invest in those companies
and
uh and that was an idea i had uh i did
uh
i remember um i wanted to reinvent forks
i was obsessed with forks because like
fork is just so it's like and then i and
then i started
i realized my problem before so i was
things were falling off of it i wanted
to okay yeah let's break this down a
little bit what a drinking problem what
about standard forks do you hate now
just it's just it hasn't evolved that is
where the do you think they should be
deeper i think they should be well i
really haven't evolved either well i
know neither are chopsticks but but like
i wanted what i really wanted i was um
like i wanted a trigger right and i
wanted like a monkey fist that would
grab this oh i like those things like
grab it and then put it in your mouth
like if you had a baby feeding you you
know esther's definitely into this i
know why haven't you done it yeah
i want to hire esther's little hand to
feed me so it captures the food and it
releases it so nothing is wasted or goes
through the fork no you you like salad's
so difficult for me
i have a heart we can tell
nobody's you know what my daughter said
that made me laugh so hard we're
watching a documentary on like gandhi i
think and uh it was talking about his
hunger strike and i just was like i'm
drinking wine on the couches and i go
you know i just don't get hunger strikes
and isla goes no [ __ ]
um the the i think here's the problem
though i've gotten to a place where a
couple of my ideas have landed right so
like when i when i came up with to drive
a movie theater i called my agent my
managers and i was like i want to drive
a movie theaters it's covered and
they're like there's that's not a thing
they're there are there even drive-ins i
remember nick saying do they still have
drive-ins and i was like i was like i
don't know you can you guys check and
then he called me one day super excited
and he was like um
hey man drive-ins are a thing and i
think i can get you some like are you
really into this and i was like yeah get
me a company that can produce it and so
then that was the first time and then
once you have a weird idea and someone
goes i can help you do it then you're
stuck in a in a new position where
you're like well [ __ ] am i are these
dumb ideas am i just because he
initially got me 12 dates and i was like
i was like i can't i can't commit what
if they suck what if this is horrible i
was like can you cut it down to four and
he was like yeah and so we just did one
weekend no money made to be made we did
one weekend and after at the first one
and we did in uh greensboro north
carolina i was like
i'm doing this all summer i'm doing this
all year and we ended up doing 70 dates
didn't 35 cities yeah like it was i mean
but that's where i'm at now is like
whatever idea i have people are like
let's do it the cabin's a great [ __ ]
example is you come up with an idea and
you think it's funny and you're laughing
about it and then
netflix is like let's do it and then
you're like oh [ __ ] we didn't really
think this through you know and then
especially you know when you go into the
production of that and we have no
scripts we have nothing we had all
everything kind of fell apart because of
you know timing and
when we decided to shoot it
that's when like the [ __ ] every idea
i have now everyone's like i love it
let's do it and you're like hold on i
need someone to tell me i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] every now and then
but yeah i can't wait to get to yes man
level
can we talk about saying goodbye to high
interest credit card debt and it's one
of the first steps toward financial
independence yeah we've all been there
seemingly out of nowhere you get hit
with all of these unexpected expense or
bills and when that happens it can feel
like the weight of the world is coming
down when you're saying i honestly know
as someone who's just getting out of
this situation
it's such a relief to be able to have
something like upstart to help me with
it because it it can seem so
overwhelming yeah and it's just a place
where everything is consolidated it's
easy to follow you can track one thing
on one app and you don't lose your mind
or your
you know you just don't stress out over
it upstart powered personal loans can
help you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms and you can
even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan i
know what it's like to be so stressed
out the first thing you think of in the
morning is like oh my god did i do that
did i forget to pay this off all these
things like just get help with with this
app you really have the option to not
just be your credit score you can fix it
it's like just start fixing it it's just
like doing it seems overwhelming when
you think of all of them but upstart
just consolidates the upstart model
considers other factors like your income
your employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
yeah so this is all about just seeing if
you can find a better interest rate so
you end up paying less over time don't
wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com
tuesday
that's upstart.com tuesday to check your
rate today don't forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you and loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application and you can go to
upstart.com
tuesday
[Music]
well i wanted to get a muse for the bus
right so i wanted a muse what is a muse
muse like uh like uh julia fox julia fox
josh safety come on master
remember yes no but i didn't realize you
could just go out and get a like what
[Applause]
you hold your hand when you do well i
was doing it like
guys always call me out for that too
because i'm always like well i made it
really like yeah and stretchy horrible
i'm horrible at hand jobs i just have a
joke about your head
if someone broke into our house and was
like that's it i'm gonna call everyone
in this room unless someone give me a
semi-tolerable somewhat dry
mediocre earthy type of hand job
i got this lamb
[Laughter]
the uh
the what were we just saying you were
talking about
so that clip goes viral right if we're
going i mean his mess
right and i and i thought
what if that's real
like for real now i'm always thinking
content right so like part of me goes
um
i would like to
we do a weekly vlog on for the boss for
the tour and so i thought what if we got
amused what if we
hired a muse in new york city some model
some flighty like almost like kate
hudson and almost famous flighty uh dope
smoking macrame wearing like kind of
like esther's seeing if she can do it
i'm watching
i think i'm amused because i just want
to stand there
i'm amused that you think you're amused
trust me i'm born to be amused i have
ideas all the time and then and then i
lose interest in an idea very quickly
like i did a podcast i started a podcast
called open tabs where i would take all
my
all my safari browser i just leave all
the tabs open and then on monday i'd
come on the road i come in i open my
computer and i close the tabs with
people watching i think it's genius yeah
it was all the weird stuff i was into
like like i was into this uh there was
this flash flood chaser that i was like
[ __ ] obsessed in fact open your tabs
now bert
we can all open our table it's gonna be
i guarantee you it's gonna be ticket
sales and [ __ ] fully loaded festival
or at the greek on may 5th
this is fun this is fun and it's
scary it's very scary
well
i know what one is one there are a lot
of them are wordle yeah mine's wordless
yeah
wordle my facebook because i was looking
for my face all three of you use wordle
what's wrong what's wrong with me okay
this could get do you want us to answer
one of mine is sloth beagle i don't know
why
all right i'm gonna very very candidly
run through all of them okay
omicron variant
okay uh twitter cancel that tampa improv
i was checking to see
uh akash singh was at the tampa improv
now this is the fun part is explaining
why you're there right yeah across the
tampa and probably asked me to get you
together i like your glasses cowhead
thank you uh dune there's uh zendaya and
i'm doon i don't know who zendaya is oh
my god but i know the name and i know
that i know what she looks like but i
don't know how i've ever known her and i
haven't seen dune okay so i was like
trying to figure out how do i know
zendaya you got to know zendaya and
everyone's like spider-man i go never
seen spider-man oh did you you don't
watch euphoria you probably can't by the
way this one's sketchy let's see
i got it i got to check to see what is
it isn't it zendaya
it's zendaya the young girl knows
she's everything zinda is the whole gen
z intern she's all she's all things
zendaya is michie anyone remember that
song no okay some of these are some of
these are things that i don't know why i
open them and then i get to it and i say
it out loud and then i realize ooh i
always hate googling that oh mine is
healing uh ptsd drama
i'm so curious why you would hate google
because you're so you have such a like
good energy it's like someone that does
something mean to one of my friends oh
okay that's understanding uh okay here's
uh i don't know why i googled her oh i
do know why i googled her
dad
no
amy landecker do you know who she is i
love her she's so beautiful i don't i
don't know who she is
but she was married to bradley whitford
who i said yes
i sat behind on a plane and i couldn't
figure it out i love her
she was in an episode of alone together
you guys she is so lovely and talented
and she was also great in handmaid's
tale she was there she wasn't so good in
handmaid's tale what was that show she
was on there too
transparent oh she wasn't transparent
transparent like one of my favorite
shows also instagram audit because there
was a girl that i was like there's no
way this [ __ ] has this many followers
and only this many likes and then i was
correct
james charles james she only had 44
people why were you looking at you he
was also on a loan together were you
watching alone together
he's also like what is wonderful
together i might have watched the loan
together no i'm kidding no you
definitely need to if you're just
googling things you don't know then
definitely google alone together
george lopez
let me see if this is a bad one the
world's best massage
picture of dog skin michael roof this
guy is so important
to guys my age in stand-up comedy
michael roof uh
in 2012 under the stage named chicken
he uh
he was the guy that killed development
deals in hollywood yes so he got a
because of montreal all right huge like
six figure development deal for like a
750 000
and they couldn't build a show around
them they tried to do a show called hype
with frank galiendo and it kind of
failed and he ended up getting some bit
parts here and there but he never really
and i'm trying to speak respectfully
because i
i met the guy i knew the guy um he was
good friends with reno collier there was
a whole group of us all moved to
hollywood at the same time we all got
deals we all were class or two behind
dane and bill and all those guys
but um cosby michael roof then uh killed
himself he ended up uh hanging himself
in front of an elementary school
and so i i was and so the reason i
googled him is because um
the brothers who are the brothers that
did the league you know the the two
they're really talented they just did
the documentary
no no they they're really talented
brothers you're not talking about the
duplo duplosses yeah bosses yeah they
they were saying hey man who should we
do a documentary on and i was like
michael roof that's who i would do a
documentary on that because it's so
fascinating that period of time is when
hollywood changed to where we are today
that period michael roof is the canary
in the mind that says hey what's the
chicken in the mine
wait that's why i love being around
comedian
is is i called uh i called um
i called uh
asia argenta
on a podcast
and someone goes
are you worried about that and i said
actually i have no reservations
wait why do you hate us
because because uh i
i don't know have you seen lamb i don't
really i really don't know why have you
have you ever read limits you know leo
mcsweeney she's on the new york
housewives she's [ __ ] it's like weird
she's on the new york housewives because
she's i knew her from this whole other
thing but she wrote this this a couple
articles for i think it was for playboy
or penthouse or something during the
metoo movement i want to get her on here
so she is so [ __ ] good but
she is brilliant but she wrote a whole
thing on the the background of asia
argenta and uh or asia agenda and um
rose mcgowan and what happened with the
anthony bourdain thing that was [ __ ]
unbelievable
i i kind of i kind of look at
i don't know i i think ultimately the
reason i disliked her is i blamed her
for anthony bourdain stuff yeah
i think i think he died
that's how i that's how i processed it i
have a different yeah everyone everyone
does
that
you can't blame someone for someone
you're right because then i'd be blamed
for three dudes in college
right because i called them gay once no
carlos the uh the i i have a lot of
friends that have killed themselves
carlos is on suicide watch um
let's see if we got anything best coast
smoky mountains per chrysler burke rice
you're my ceo i know i was like how many
are going to be a battle of waterloo bad
flowers to buy for a funeral um can you
tell us what you found out about that
bad flowers to buy for a funeral yep
yeah that's in what well
yeah it's like who are these greedy dead
people that are like these are actually
not the ones i want i think that roses
are not it right
like white's good uh
white is traditional yeah
they uh red says it's poor etiquette yes
poor at right there should not be edited
you're getting flowers you're welcome we
know who you're [ __ ] dead people so i
just want to say for my funeral i don't
want flowers i want chocolates so
um you're not gonna be able to eat them
oh that's the one you can eat them
that's when you're dead
are we allowed to shove them in your
mouth is it an open castle oh i'm gonna
stuff all your holes with them because i
oh my goodness
flowers in life so
esther what else do you want sometimes i
like your horses wait wait tell me why
you don't like flowers because they love
to die you do because they don't take
care of them they die it's like i want i
would rather eat chocolates than have
flowers that's interesting
so when i met leanna she had a cat and i
couldn't spend the night at her house
because i because i had allergies and it
was a it was a rift in our relationship
she dumped me and when we got back
together she said one of the things we
were dating four months she said
i want to be able to spend the night in
my house with my cat and not just spend
the night your house only like if we're
gonna get serious you need to get
allergy medicine so i go to this allergy
doctor and he gives me allergy medicine
i'd never been able to breathe through
my nose never never same here yes
and
i come back and i go to my house and i
go
what's that smell my buddy goes what do
you mean what's that smell i said what
am i smelling
what is that smell
and he goes it's uh what's this stuff
that grows on vine that's a white and
it's like a stripper's name
um ivy no no no no no
no no
stripper names stripper names uh cardi b
no
no no what's the stuff that uh that's
white and it's and it's gr it grows on
candy with an eye no no no no uh gross
on vines it's my favorite now it's it's
my favorite thing i have it all over my
house
jasmine jasmine that's a stripper name
yeah jasmine it might just be a girl
that's a pretty good name yeah you're
white if you're white and so i walked in
i walked in to our house and i went what
is that smell and he goes
what do you mean what smell i said this
our house smells amazing i've been
living in this house for like 13 months
and i was like what is that and he was
like it's uh
you talking about jasmine i go it smells
[ __ ] awesome i go down to my room my
room reeks of jasmine i'd never smelled
it and i went this is [ __ ] awesome so
then i went to a flower store
i've been to flower stores never knew
what they smelled never knew that they
smelled i walked in all of a sudden i'm
like i want to smell everything i want
to smell it so they just walked me
through i smelled rose i was like okay
didn't love it
[ __ ] casablanca lily
get the [ __ ] out is anyone else
surprised that when he first was able to
smell it smelled good
[Applause]
funny that you love that because they're
toxic to cats they can kill they can
cause renal faith failure and did that
happen i would buy it i would buy leanne
castle
i
love castle blanket lilies and so like i
wear diane's flowers where i get my
flowers for leanne it's right on little
canyon every time i call she goes uh
like this year uh for valentine's day i
called and she goes you're late and i
said well she goes i've been holding on
to casper like lily's for you you're
late and i was like yeah so i cause i
get them now i get them for the girls
and leanne
but um i love the small casper i love
the smell i like it
i used to not like it wow it's like it's
similar to when i got my reading glasses
and uh
and leanne gave me a she goes you look
cute and i was like oh yeah they're cool
they're like you want to give me a kiss
and i was like whoa i haven't seen this
[ __ ] in high definition
what the [ __ ] happened to your face
i was like break these glasses all being
nice to you too
by the way you're making me realize why
i don't like flowers because i don't
like like smells strong sense
yeah so that's interesting i can't deal
with there's a flower i can't deal with
um it's the one that sits in water
it's uh it's like you can get a special
vase for it
um i forget chris chrysant not
chrysanthemum but like chrysanthemums
chrysanthemums i wish i was better at
remembering names well lily's like calla
lilies you can work on that there's
certain lilies that today yeah
yeah wait
[Music]
[Applause]
um we usually on the show we take a
banana break so you're welcome to join
us uh it's okay all right let's take
some time and see how everyone does it
oh wait you're you're a top guy yeah
you're a real ape you just break it in
half no not a [ __ ] gorilla
no i'm like i'm i'm on the i might save
mine today i'm just a regular person i
just eat them regularly but i do like
he's if he opens i want to see you doing
it i'm just a person i'm not an animal
no why do you do that uh i don't know i
think it's the same reason i say
benafleck into two
it's just i like to be different and i
like people to notice it at a time you
know you're doing that wrong and i go
yeah i know i was at a party one time
and they were um this woman was cutting
an avocado and she was doing it wrong i
didn't know this woman and i went you're
cutting that wrong you want to excuse me
i didn't know this one we're a party
full of people i don't know that's fair
she goes
i'm
i'm good no no no no i'm she goes you're
welcome you don't know why she was she
was uh
she was what was she oh she was i mean
she was peeling the outside no [ __ ] she
was
outside everyone knows that peeling the
outside and i go
but you but you're doing it wrong and
she goes i don't know you
and why are you talking to me like this
i said well initially this is the truth
i go initially i thought you were my
wife
so i saw my wife doing that i was like
you're doing it wrong and then i
realized after i said it that you're not
but i still should tell you you're doing
that wrong and she goes i feel bad for
your wife i said i feel bad for your
husband that's how you cut that's how
you peel avocados and then her husband
goes i've been telling her she's been
doing it wrong forever and she was what
she would do she'd peel the outside and
then she'd
like shave it like she was doing a
papaya
you know like papaya
avocado was she working with
yeah papaya you there's several ways to
do papaya [ __ ] hard depending if you
want the greener papaya like the harder
and you add vinegar and salt to it then
you you peel it if it's already a little
bit mushier then you cut it in between
and you just take the seeds out you cut
it no no i'm doing i'm thinking i'm
thinking the wrong thing though mango
mango mangoes yeah i was imagining mango
is you gotta cut it's the weirdest
[ __ ] so you lose a lot of fruit
i come from the country where our
biggest import is mango this is a mango
country there is no way there's no wrong
way to do a mango because there's a good
way yeah is it a ripe mango is it a
green mango is it a carabao mango is it
a red mango i honestly thought there was
one what's like the normal mango that
like like over here we get the mexican
mango okay so you can peel it and if
it's not too mushy or ripe then you can
just peel it and then slice it
accordingly but if it is mushy and sweet
then you cut it in the middle
right okay
and
are you listening you cut it not in the
middle you cut it on each side around
the seeds yes and then but you don't
waste the seed you so you you scoop each
side each um side of the mango and then
you suck the sides of the seed out yeah
it gets in your teeth though right i was
in um i went to central america when i
was a kid when i was like 17 i went on a
like
i graduated early and went to central
america and did a bunch of service work
and richard it was not religious but it
was weird um but one of the things we
did we were in guatemala and we went
spelunking
and we had so we had we had just gone
through like
these like caves these tiny little like
tubes of caves or i mean
i
am very glad i'm not claustrophobic
because i probably would have died in
there but i mean
covered in mud just covered so dirty and
then i got a mango and i was just eating
it like this and it was stuck in my
teeth but my fingers were covered with
mud and it was the worst experience of
my life like i there was just hours or
the strings of mango so i don't want to
bite the [ __ ] seed i don't want to
[ __ ] bite the seed there's the part
of the seed
it's like depending on how ripe or
unripe the mango is it's grainier the
seed is oh it was just the it was so
after can i tell you can i tell you a
parallel side thought yes so i have this
thing that i do where if you tell a
story
my instinct and i i and i want to do it
to connect my ending instinct is to tell
you my spell i want to hear your
splunking story i want to tell you the
side story of this i'm last night last
night we take georgia and two of our
friends out to eat
and one of the little girls
wants to tell
the story of
swimming with sharks in hawaii and
georgia has swam with sharks in hawaii
probably four times and my instinct is i
hear the stories to then also tell my
story
but more importantly i'm waiting for
georgia to go oh yeah we've actually
done that but we did that and tell her
story and george it didn't
she's listening to the girl's story
to kick her shin under the camera in the
car and i and i say to georgia how come
you didn't tell her that you went
swimming with sharks and she goes
because she was telling me she swam with
sharks and i went yeah but why didn't
you then go oh yeah i've done that and
she goes because she doesn't need to
know she had a special story and i
wanted her oh my god that would never be
[ __ ]
i was like what kind of [ __ ] animal
are you you just let someone
have the spotlight
and you just said that was a great story
that must have been a great experience
and then just letter and i was like oh
my god i go whatever [ __ ] kid leanne
raised is killing it
but then part of me wanted to go hey
just so you know that's how you relate
to people like oh yeah i did that also
she was yeah but swimming shark's like a
big deal
and i think the girl was like proud to
tell her story everyone's gonna be like
yeah we've all done it oh especially if
he's like i've done this four times yeah
yeah but what if you could be like isn't
it fun when you're swimming in the shark
and this happens like this thing you
really can't really like so there's only
very well i do like what i do so you go
you say uh
over in holly evo right
yeah so what i do is i because i it's
too transparent if i go oh i've done
that you know like what i do is uh have
you ever had the uh the shaved ice with
the coconut with the now i don't know
off of it right now
what i try to do is then go
i i i've also done that but i wanna i
wanna move the story forward and i'm
thinking if you've done that you've
probably had that shaved ice and then we
can keep having conversations about how
great hawaii is right that's what so
that's what i truly tried on the podcast
not in real life i'll just tell you that
when i didn't did it also but on the
podcast because i've noticed that i that
when people tell me their story i just
then tell them my experience with that
and my experience is always going to be
a hundred times better because i'm a
great storyteller and i travel the world
for [ __ ] six years on travel channel
so like when you say when you say
spelunking i've got this i've got the
splunking story that is the best funking
story you're ever going to [ __ ] hear
mine was a bad story
it's like you're just miserable oh my
[ __ ] title i was miserable too
following them we had to go through a
birthing canal where you were so scary
and then they we had to go up a [ __ ]
it was the most terrifying they would
then take us in the cave where your
mouth head was like this and the top of
the thing was here and you were going
like this just breathing and it's like
nine of us going like [ __ ] are we gonna
make it out of here we're in new zealand
we all got chest
infections i mean
it was the [ __ ] most terrifying thing
i've ever done at one point we had to go
climb up a waterfall so he goes it's a
10 second climb you need to hold your
breath for at least 10 seconds so they
put us behind the waterfall and you go
all right go and he'd pull you out and
you had to climb up a waterfall and it's
just gushing over and you're going when
does this [ __ ] end and the best part
of the story is when we got out the crew
that was shooting on the outside had no
idea what we experienced on the inside
and they're like all right everyone gave
the van and we were all crying we're
like
get the van give me a beer i need to
[ __ ] decompress we thought we were
gonna [ __ ] die and they're like was
it bad we're like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
but yeah but that would be me by the way
in the car i'm like whoa what was so bad
because i was too scared to go all of a
sudden she's the driver of the car she
like takes that role that was something
i deep dove on open tabs is there's
these dudes who go spelunking and they
go into places where their arm and their
head are stuck in the hospital and they
chisel to kind of get their head through
dude i would deep dive
do not by the way
do not even look at spelunking accidents
where people fall into a crevasse and
they're like help
help
help
that's all over youtube can someone tell
me what is spelunking it's like wait no
no no no let her figure it out on her
own one day she's gonna go that's
splunky
it is a ridiculous name though it is an
outrageous name and you do want to talk
about it what do you think what does it
sound like esther is it climbing through
a cave
it's yeah it's going into the cave you
go into like the little like crevasses
yeah oh sp this is what's wrong with me
crevasses we went ice climbing one time
in alaska and they take us into crevasse
and what we were doing what he did is
he'd lowest down 100 feet then we had to
ice climb our way out of the crevasse he
gets me down 100 feet and as i hit the
thing the first time i hear
god
smack the earth with thor's hammer it is
the loudest thing i've ever heard in my
life
it reverbs in the crevasse the crevasse
i feel air rushed through the crevasse
and this guy just looks over the gun and
he goes you still there yeah and i look
up i go i am he goes we're getting out
right now
so i get out he just pulls me out we do
a little bit of ice climbing at the top
he gets out and i go so what was that
and he goes
uh just uh one of the bosses collapsed
and i said what would have happened if
that if i was in there and he goes
he'd be gone forever and i was like what
he's like you just be you'd be gone
you'd be gone
were they paying you well for the show
uh
i was getting paid i think twelve
thousand dollars an episode yeah that's
not enough for okay you're like
like the fact that you've had all these
near-death experiences like how are you
a completely different person because of
those where you're just like [ __ ] he
has anxieties up all night oh ptsd i had
one day where i swam with great white
sharks in south africa i rappelled off
table mountain and i jumped off a
stadium the top of a stadium by like 610
feet
within one day that's within one day 12
hour day i sat on the corner of my bed
shaking that night and i'd been drinking
and i was like i guess i gotta i should
jack off or something like and so when i
got done doing travel channel i came
home and i was i'd fallen off a
waterfall and i had i [ __ ] my back up
and i was i was eating pain pills and
valium like crazy and and we were
supposed to go camping with our family
this is when leanne this is when liam
was like
we're done we're done we're fixing this
we went uh we i was addicted to oxy and
uh valium i was eating them my doctor
told me to take four take one every four
hours did you [ __ ] at all you must have
been so constantly i was i hate being
constipated i have no [ __ ] idea
and so
i woke up the morning we're supposed to
go camping we had to go to costco that
day and so i was like well if i could
walk her in costco definitely need some
pills
and liam was standing in my bed and had
right next to my bed and had both pills
and she goes you're done and i went what
she was you're done and i went no no no
baby i need i can't go camping without
i'm gonna need pills for this weekend
and she goes no you don't she goes
you're done and she went in and dumped
him in the toilet and poured him out and
i was like she had caught me trying to
get a prescription from another doctor
how long have you been just for the
month uh
it was pr probably maybe a month i guess
and did you pull off like when you get
[ __ ] up i think you probably the
reason you're able to party so hard is
because you can pull it off right you're
still able to kind of like perform
yourself i was no you could no it's when
the
no i was fine on the pills but the
second i didn't have a pill you could
see it in my personality liam's always
been able to see it in my personal liane
can tell if i'm doing anything she can
yeah sniff it out so she was like uh
uh go over i have an appointment for a
marijuana doctor you can go over and get
marijuana you can smoke marijuana all
weekend um but you're not eating pills
anymore and so i went over i got a
prescription for marijuana i got
marijuana we went to costco i got high
in the parking lot with her at costco
and i was and my back felt better and i
went okay however the withdrawals that
weekend camping
is one of our
a fight that she will bring up and
giggle about
and i it's like it's like where you
cringe where you go i can't believe i
said that she's like i knew it wasn't
you talking it was someone else it was
it was pills talking but uh
i had hardcore ps ptsd we got back in
camping she goes you're going into
therapy immediately
you have ptsd
and uh and you need to [ __ ] deal with
this because this she's like this isn't
healthy now you're like urged to do
things because i am very much like a
daredevil like and it's not that i like
choose the things but i once asked i
must
complete is that what you have if if you
say something to me
like if you go hey uh
dude uh we're all gonna go do this i
immediately go i'm in yeah
i'm in 100 and then i and then do you
try to get out and the next what do you
try to get out of it afterwards oh yeah
my boyfriend's always like why do you
say i'm always like yep be right there
and he's like what you don't want to go
tom said to me the other day he calls me
up and he's like uh in austin stem cells
you in i was like yes 100
and then i'm in my bunk and i'm going
what i don't know what the [ __ ] am i
doing
what does that even mean i don't even i
don't even know i i just said he just
said something that rogan says all the
time and that all right like i'm a stem
cell what do you mean
and i tried to get out of it and i tried
to get out of it hard as [ __ ] and then
uh
and then we got to the stem cell place
and it was really chill and they were
cool and then they were like do you want
it and i was like what does it do and
then like it just it finds your
inflammation it finds your broken parts
it starts to heal them that's all and i
went they're like you're not gonna have
a stroke you're not that was my thing i
have a stroke and they were like so they
gave me stem cells and i was
fine and do you feel better i loved it
i'm going back
to my parents but so i kind of have the
same thing where it's like i agree
i'm down then i'm like wait what is this
but then if someone can like explain it
to me i can go along with it but
sometimes i just need a little bit of
skydiving this is a perfect example
rachel ray was like you want to go
skydiving
yeah and that's why i went together like
i make pancakes
she's aware of her she's favorite i
haven't been scared i once got
everything well god sorry no but
skydiving skydiving i was bored by it i
was terrified
oh i was like this is [ __ ] [ __ ] i was
like
i just did you go tandem yeah see i was
like this person goes every day they're
not gonna [ __ ] die like i was like i
wanted to like know i was there was a
chat like i always say next time i go
skydiving i want to go
i want to go to a place where it's like
got a really low rating on yelp and i
want there to be a fatality within the
month and i want them when we go up on
the plane i want them to go there's two
shoots one works pic this is wrong
that's that's my type of skydiving
i do think that i moved i think i've
moved past this because i'm in love now
and i feel like i love my life but but
like on suicide watch by the way but no
i'm not suicidal anyway i love my life
but i don't feel this anymore but you're
on suicide watch because you're called
out of your homosexuality but
um
several times and my neck does still
hurt from when you we did a thing last
night and we did the the shock collar
the dog shock collar
i adapt her one extra time on accident
and she yelled you are gay
i was trying to hold back something else
i wanted to say
of similar
i was like am i really getting canceled
for this moment i really was like
[Laughter]
but i my it was on this side so my seat
belt was rubbing i was like oh i got to
remember this side next time
oh after the stem cells my my arm my arm
went numb oh it's like you lost your
mind and i was in the car with tom and i
was like and and he can see me playing
with my arm and i'm like
and he goes and he's driving he goes
you're okay buddy
okay he's like everyone loves you you're
fine nothing's happening i don't want
you you're right you're right you're
right can i do you have veneers no yes
so i gotta talk [ __ ] on them not yours
you ready okay so we're getting ready to
do a movie
and uh
i make a appointment to get my all my
veneers all my veneers fixed yeah like i
want them i want a perfect one
and uh
leanne goes i can't let that nope thank
you
she goes she goes you look she goes it's
it's distracting it doesn't work and it
doesn't fit it doesn't do what you think
it's going to do you want to look
perfect on screen that's not who you are
right you are those teeth teeth are you
yes and she was like and i was like yeah
but
it's like you see in the comment
sections but what the [ __ ] wrong with
your teeth and you're like you're like
this is what teeth look like like teeth
like they look they're not perfect
there's like a dark one i may get that
one fixed but like they're jerry can i
just say honestly like
those are the only veneers i've ever
liked like because they don't look
perfect but i'm telling you no i'm
telling you it makes me so upset it
upsets me it feels like to me and i i'm
not trying to like come down on people
but it's like you're [ __ ] they don't
fit in your mouth right people have like
a lisp for a year it just looks weird
and perfect and it you grind your true
teeth down to a [ __ ] nub i see this a
lot when you give up your real teeth
it's like and i love your stuff you get
but you it's so interesting i'm like why
because i'm like i don't care well to me
it's because no i don't care what other
people do but it's like to me it's like
i don't want people to get like you're
quitting your own family i think what
she's saying is that there's a really
big like seat on tick tock a lot like
where people have like even nicer teeth
than me but they want perfect teeth
right like people like they think their
gap is it's like something that's their
little dance their little like their
little thing you know like makes them
their thing like i just want them to
have like have your special little thing
be like real be like it's just oh it's
true i got the clap from a girl i was
dating and i knew i had only had sex
with her i knew that
and i went to the doctor and i told the
doctor uh i think because i'd gone
hiking in switzerland before that and i
was and i'd be dranking out of a trough
i think i got it from a troll in
switzerland then he goes was there a
[ __ ] in the troll
i was like by the way he was he was like
probably uh 27 i thought he was a grown
up he was just a doctor he was just like
some kid fries out of med school because
he worked at school but he was like was
there a [ __ ] in the trough and i was
like huh and i was like this doesn't
sound doctorly and then he's like uh
he's like no man you gotta have a neural
disease he's got the clap i just give
you the medicine and i was like no i'm
pretty sure i've only been with one i've
been with two chicks at the time and in
my life and he goes i'm 22 and he's like
uh he's like no it's i mean i can give
you the test but the tat
i can give you the test i'm gonna give
you the pills anyway so just take the
pills and just get rid of it don't worry
about the test it's what it is and i
went no i'm being serious i don't think
it is because i've only been with two
chicks and he was like
he's like hey man i think your your
girlfriend's sleeping around and i was
like
no and he goes dumb man
i'm i i
put money on it that she's a [ __ ] and i
was like what a [ __ ] yeah and he goes
he goes well he goes you he goes she
gave you this for nero disease she gave
it to you you
if you're lying to me
he goes are you are you lying to me and
i went no he said you've been with two
chicks nobody doesn't sound real right
i'm 22 years old and i'm like a cool guy
or whatever and he goes let me ask you a
question when you go to yani's there's
the bar we are in tallahassee do you and
your dick split up to cover more
territory and i went
no and he goes
he goes then your chicks lying to you
she's sleeping with someone else
and i went i don't believe he goes fine
i'll give you the test and he goes
you're not gonna like it so you take
your dick out pulls out a [ __ ]
gorilla
swab
and shoves it
down the head of your [ __ ]
a mid [ __ ] swirls it it's as soon as he
did i went she's a [ __ ]
and then and then the conversation i had
with her
after i got diagnosed with chlamydia the
conversation was mind-numbing was
mind-numbing i haven't slept with anyone
and i went
hold on
like all right where how gat what are
the only ones in the room [ __ ] i hate
when people lie to you and you're like
there's no one else here yeah and i was
i remember going like when i go beyond
my dick don't split up to cover more
territory
and i remember just being like
it was like mind-blowing did you
consider it ever that she was telling me
like were you like
getting gaslit yeah
completely like am i crazy maybe there's
another way you can get it or she had
someone get on the phone and pretend
to
say that they were the doctor oh my gosh
tell me that and i was and i now i'm
going like sweet how did i get chlamydia
like what to be fair though the fact
that the doctor came out the gates and
was like oh is there horror in there i'm
like maybe he like maybe maybe he gave
you fake chlamydia
i think all women were [ __ ] oh this by
the way i i remember thinking he was a
girl maybe he was [ __ ] her it sounds
like he was so sure he's like i got the
same thing
i found out she had sex with someone
else and i found out and then
progressively throughout the time i
would talk to other people like oh yeah
i had sex with her too and i was like
for real i remember and i remember i
remember getting i was already broken up
with her and getting
outraged again going like i've done my
best to not sleep around yeah it doesn't
matter because of this one person oh my
gosh bert thank you so much for making
our dreams come true
this was so fun and you being here is
such like good energy supportive like
thank you also bert i wanna thank you
because you were the first person when
we first started the show that reached
out and asked us to be on your show even
though we had scheduling conflicts and
stuff but you pretended to be mark maron
and i was like that is the weirdest wtf
i could imagine
he was like it's me mark maron
i come to my pocket and bert we still
have to go spearfishing
we got that we got that set up what we
got to do is we just have to do a show
in hawaii when we will take fully loaded
to hawaii and we'll all go down to
hawaii we'll do a big festival in hawaii
everyone will come out and then because
i want to go surfing to i want to go
spearfishing there's
are you good at surfing no horrible i'm
talking about yesterday
i love that i know i i might never
matter i've done i've done it a couple
times i've stood up i've caught my own
wave and stood up a couple times but i'm
so fat poor kid the poor kid yesterday
saw me the surfboard he's the sweetest
kid in the world he just goes
yeah he said uh
you should try getting up off the ground
a couple times you know what and he goes
i'm just saying like
and you could see that he was like
you're really fat can you get up off the
ground and he was like like just
before you go out there maybe like
before you have to wave see if you can
get off the ground like see if you can
get up on your feet and he was like and
he was like i don't mean this mean but
like like he goes people do it like and
he was like you could see him walking up
back and i was like it's okay i wanted
to buy running shoes one time and i said
can i try these asics on and the guy
looked at me what are you getting them
for
running and he goes
for you're you're gonna wear him you
know what
yeah and he's like oh okay yeah sure and
i was like
holy [ __ ]
yeah that's happened to me a few times
and then someone called you fat and
you're like i'm not fat what the hell's
going on i just i'm so [ __ ] up that i
i'll see a picture of myself and i'll go
on fat but like right now i feel very
skinny you look strange i feel very
skinny i don't know how you feel you
you're great i wish i could just deflate
my face
no your team big face like no you take a
gift yeah are you kidding me
the fat in our face keeps us young
yeah you actually will look old if you
got skinny face it's a weird [ __ ] up
thing that happens to like if you like
over exercise it's not like yeah it's
like imagine how many people pay to get
fillers to fatten up and to plump up
your faces you would naturally have that
bird
look at that puffy beautiful young
red-cheeked
[ __ ] my dad one time we were doing we
went uh white water rafting when i was
little
and he was fat and he they had trained
us all like we went with a couple
different families that we didn't know
but they trained us like when someone
falls out give them a bear hug and bring
them up
my dad falls out and this little kid
just starts crying he's like i can't
give him a bear hug i can't cuz they're
so [ __ ] fat
like they you've been like can you jump
up on this board i wish i could just
lose weight and
like uh
maintain your same life no i i wish i
like because i even when i was people
still called me fat i was pretty skinny
like i was 220 225 for one of my
specials and everyone's like look at
that fact i take a shirt off i'm going
to go i would be cool with 220 being fat
i could be called fat at 220. at 253
you're like legit fat where you got to
take a deep breath and then your height
is not fat uh it's not skinny but it's
like the kind like the plush that i'm
into i love a 220 25 by the way i
realize you're dating bobby the maybe
not the best
maybe not the best sounding board people
discovered that a lot halfway through a
conversation with her and they're like
oh that i've had it happen she's like
yesterday i find you attractive i'm like
that's because i look like bobby lee um
thank you thank you guys for having me
when are we gonna when are you guys
gonna come to my podcast i would love to
talk to you have let's do it alright
let's do it talk to them
let's talk about it let's talk about a
trash tuesday
uh something out on the road with fully
loaded though
we just want to be on that plane with
you baby well that's that's part of the
thing is i'm trying leanne right now is
we had a call and she said
ignore bert's money that he's making on
this i'm gonna try to walk out breaking
e me not losing any money but to put it
back into the artist so that that
everyone goes like like just making
everything a little extra nicer so that
every because the con this festival only
succeeds if every comic goes can i be on
next year that's the only way it
succeeds because then ev then everyone's
like hey man how do i get on fully
loaded and you're like that's what you
want so i listened to ryan leaf talk
about his contract with he was a
football player he played for san diego
and they call him the biggest bust in
the nfl and he said what i thought when
i signed that first contract i had made
it what i didn't realize it's the second
contract and i am aware that this
festival only succeeds if there's a
second year of it in order to second
year everyone has to have a great time
the fans have to [ __ ] love it the
fans have to love it has to be an
experience for the fans it's got to be
better than anything they've seen
and
and but every comic has to walk away
going that was funny yeah that is such
the entrepreneurial spirit because like
what company profits in its first year
you have to spend and invest and make it
really good yeah
that's good rogan's like that too with
his club where he's like i just hit
rogan's just like i have too much money
he's like i just want everyone to get
paid well and have a good time
whenever that [ __ ] thing comes up
opens jesus in like three i'm like thank
you everyone thank you guys bert and i
are not a good people to end podcast
i just keep talking everything
[Music]
[Music]